let's look at um here's a question that
we've been asking for a while
and that question is
are all of these investigations into
Trump going to hurt his approval rating
and on the one hand
if approval
reacted to the real world the answer
would be it sure as hell should look at
all of the legal trouble and wrongdoing
that we've learned about just in the
last six weeks about Donald Trump but
when you're dealing with a cult it
doesn't always work that way
and indeed Trump's support Remains
unmoved by investigations poll finds
this is in the New York Times is the
upshot and it says even during Peak
crises during his presidency views of
him were static post-presidency polls
have continued the trend
the American public's view of trump
is remarkably stable across a number of
different measures in recent months even
as he faces multiple investigations and
remains a central figure in the midterm
elections this is a New York Times Siena
College poll and it finds 44 percent of
Voters view Trump favorably 53 percent
view him unfavorably the recent poll was
fielded early this month after news of
the Justice Department's inquiry into
Trump's handling of confidential
documents but before yesterday the day
before yesterday's lawsuit announcement
the level of trump support has
effectively been unchanged since the
last poll in July which was during the
January 6th committee hearings this is
occult folks and that is what we should
expect and think about it uh Jim Jones
people's Temple
this is the you know drink the Kool-Aid
disaster that we now uh know about
uh and that we've known about for
decades I should say it's not it's not
recent news if you went to the followers
of Jim Jones and you said he's under
investigation for sexual assault and
he's under investigation for
embezzlement and he's under
investigation for tax evasion and we
have pretty good evidence on all of it
do you think that Jim Jones followers
would have said oh well then I'm no I'm
not behind him anymore no because it was
a cult and that is how cult leaders work
when you don't care about reality to
start your support of trump reality
isn't going to dissuade you from your
support of trump and when he said I
could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue and
I wouldn't lose support he wasn't wrong
that's exactly right and if he did shoot
someone on Fifth Avenue we all know how
it would go it would be well he was
provoked it was self-defense there was a
violent antifa or BLM member who was
doing something to Trump that's how it
would go it wouldn't necessarily be
it's great that he shot someone although
he probably would be able to find that
uh you'd probably find some people who
say that the person he shot was one of
those pedophiles that Q Anon is fighting
against or whatever but for the most
part people go no no it was self-defense
you got to understand the circumstances
and he's there's threats to his life all
the time he reasonably feared for it and
all he's absolutely right when he said I
would be able to shoot someone on Fifth
Avenue and not lose any support so it
shouldn't surprise us that Trump's
approval hasn't diminished at all but it
raises questions about what happens with
trumpism in 2022 and in 2024 which will
be something we look at extensively in
the next few weeks leading up to these
midterm elections which are now imminent
we're now located at looking at what is
it five and a half six weeks or so from
now make sure that you're following me
on Twitter at dpacman and let me know
what you think is there anything at this
point that could erode Trump's support
among the core so supporters that are
mostly everything that he has left or
all that he has left better said